sinon tu ne peux aller à l'université
l'université viendra à 3 la fac de proxy
par et comprenait la faculté de
proximité elles existent par exemple à
cholet dans le maine-et-loire son talent
kimmerlin jacques gérard larivière
première année est les milliers
d'étudiants mais il n'a rien gagné
si ce n'est davantage incontestable de
travailler dans une petite fac de
province on a de la place pour étudier
loin des amphis bondés des grands campus
mille étudiants ici à cholet
une centaine à brive ou à colmar 1500
havane 23 mois que dans les grandes
capitales régionales complémentaire des
facs de grandes villes elle assure les
cours des deux premières années avant la
licence
même si elles sont souvent encore en
chantier les facs à la campagne déjà du
succès auprès de ceux qui sont nés en
plus j'habite à cholet donc c'est une
possibilité qui m'est offerte et j'ai
sauté dessus
je retiens moi tous les soirs et il vos
frais de logement
recensant lors restaurant c'est
nettement moins coûteux mais qui a payé
la construction de la fac
la ville de cholet pour 70% soit 30
millions de francs qui payent le
fonctionnement annuel la ville encore à
100 % y compris les heures des
enseignants soit 5 millions de francs la
fac ici n'aurait jamais vu le jour sans
la ténacité de son maire qu'il a voulu
contre vents et marées donc on veut il
faut pouvoir
il faut trouver les moyens nous voulions
pouvoir garder nos jeunes élites ashley
les garder pour assurer l'avenir
économique et sociale assurer l'emploi
assurer le développement et la création
d'entreprises donc c'est une obligation
une nécessité la ville de cholet double
la mise en 94 elle construira une
bibliothèque universitaire et en 95 un
institut universitaire technologique